and our next speaker Beyond writing
books that we're going to possibly give
away is uh not is but he takes great
pleasure in crushing his kids at
fortnite please welcome Adnan hi good
morning everyone thank you for having me
here and yes I do Crush my kids at
fortnite I had the I had the first win
and I also play Roblox and Minecraft so
thank you everyone for inviting me my
name is Adan mud I'm a machine learning
engineer an architect and a thought
leader in this space I'm also a
Microsoft Regional director by the way
that's more like U it's a honorary title
so I don't represent Microsoft so
anything I say is not Microsoft point of
view it's point of view in the general
sense but it's not like I'm not a
spokesperson from Microsoft I'm actually
a Chief Architect for AI and machine
learning my role is actually at the
intersection of Academia and Industry so
combining the best of Academia one of
the things like um generative AI for
example it has been around for a very
long long time and uh I've been doing it
before it was cool we had models which
didn't work too well and now we we had
to try multiple times and uh try
different prompts try different
engineering approaches and this has been
going on for a very long time now that
you have chat GPT you know there's no
conversation where you don't talk about
chat GPT like everybody is like oh did
you see that did you see that prompt how
work and also the most annoying thing I
think here is like people send you these
long emails and you you know that this
is from ch gbt like wow you you can so
now the brevity and the human touch has
become such a important thing right if
you see a brief email which has like
really a good point of view like this
email has personality it's written by a
human right so that's the the beauty of
uh I guess the the human touch we are
missing now um I've written uh like we
talked about the bunch of different
books one the recent one just came out
is about responsible AI so support the
starving authors please buy the book uh
but let's start with the what what
generative AI is so my talk is divided
into three different quick segments
because I only have 20 minutes and these
talks can take very long is so first
talk about generative AI as it's
offering the second is to talk about
Microsoft's ecosystem around generative
AI along with other things we have like
we have AWS we have gcp we have Azure
like these are the three major
hyperscalers so whenever you're talking
about generative AI you talk about three
major hyperscalers AWS gcp and Azure I'm
Biore Microsoft but of course those two
platforms are equally good and then we
have open Source platforms open source
models such as llama and Falcon and
Bloom and there's tons of other models
on hugging face available right so these
are the large language models which are
used I know some of you are like what
it's a completely different vocabulary
maybe but we will try to keep it a
little uh 100 level for from generative
perspective everybody knows from AI what
AI is what machine learning is what deep
learning is and what is so think about
generative AI in the sense that it's an
extension of deep learning we have these
slew of models called Transformer models
and Transformer models have come down to
the part where they have actually
created a new set of algorithms or
models which can communicate with you in
a very human looking manner but remember
these machines are not sentient right
people start thinking they're sentient
they're not sentient if I tell you the
only thing they're doing is next token
prediction that's all they're doing
right it's it's predicting the next
token in a very large hyperspace of of
words so you have words like Paris and
uh DC they're very close together in a
higher Dimension because they are both
capitals so when it's predicting
like X is the capital of France is going
to automatically know that to to
complete this sentence I need Paris in
there so this is like a really quick
introduction to how these models
actually work and now that you start
thinking in the in the sense of how
these models work your chat gbt prompts
will automatically improve because you
will try to add as much context in the
asking and the keyword in the asking
which will make it better so Chach
everybody knows about it because it's uh
it's so popular but there's tons of
other models available from because this
talk is more focused on open AI I wanted
to show some code but I think there's a
diverse audience this is the ecosystem
of azure open AI sorry Azure AI with
Microsoft so Microsoft ecosystem is not
just
dependent oh
sorry it's not just dependent
on I think ouro Lords are listening to
us I did
not the mics are ran by
AI nicely okay that might be yeah so is
there as AWS people in the room um so we
have these uh this entire ecosystem of
AI right here so for example the bar
service the cognitive sech form
recognizer and each one of these have
their implementation why because just
generative AI is not going to solve your
problem and generative AI is not a
replacement for the broader AI things
I've just showed you earlier right so
generative AI is one component of an
Enterprise ecosystem you need to have
your your Bot service to be able to
create chat Bots you have to have form
recognizer to be able to automatically
retrieve receipts and understand
components from there and be able to
extract the text out and store it in the
database so not all those components are
going away however there's a significant
impact of generative Ai and I don't like
to throw around the world game Cher but
seriously I me you have heard it here it
is a game changer for a lot of things
and I I'll talk about it quickly so
aszure open AI service most people tend
to think as open AI so let's establish a
taxonomy over here we have open AI which
is the company by Sam Alman and then we
have have the Microsoft Azure openai
that's an exclusive offering for
Microsoft from Microsoft by openai now
open AI has capabilities available but
what's the difference between open Ai
and Azure open AI the difference is
Enterprise
scalability security
reliability and also bad pixelation no
so imagine if I implementing if I'm I'm
a CEO of a company
and um start having my employees giving
access to chat GPD what could possibly
go wrong well it has a lot of things
have possibly go gone wrong number one
you must have heard of the lawyer who
have created the citations for the cases
and then submitted it to the code and I
think he almost got disbarred because of
that right because it came up with like
fake uh citations and those are called
confabulations so you can actually ask
uh chat GPT to come up with its own
facts and it will be like really sure
that that these facts are real right so
that's the that's that's called
confabulation or hallucination in
reality how can we control it well the
thing about generative a models are
there are called Auto regressive models
and auto regressive models are by design
made to do to hallucinate because we
really like it right the how it
hallucinates is what we really like to
see um Anderson horvit said um
Hallucination is when we don't like the
response and creativity is when we love
the response right so that's exactly
what it is
um so in this case if you want to give
your employees access and they are
copying and pasting your technical
design document or your private data
over in chat GPT is it secure is it kept
in for training is like there's a lot of
question marks there so that's why Azure
open AI it gives you that Enterprise
security it gives you the reliabilities
the slas the U ability to have like gdpr
compliance and Hippa compliance and PCI
compliance and all the other good things
which comes as an Enterprise platform
because it is just a part of this entire
ecosystem right so now open a Services
here but other cognitive services are
already there and these cognitive
Services already have the guard rails in
place already have the slas in place all
of those things right so open I'm sorry
open AI service is just one of those
offerings um so so that's what it does
so one thing if you can take from this
this talk is that it's not a good idea
to post your company data on chat gbd so
you can you can look it up there is tce
already have been leaks which means the
things you have been asking chat GPT
other people have read now let that sink
in um now moving to this this thing like
the Enterprise gr security with role
based Access Control what does that mean
in simple terms it means that if you are
trying to use chat gbd for your
Enterprise data it's a good idea to have
security where Finance people cannot
read the things which uh maybe HR has
been asking and vice versa so you can
apply that for your own on questioning
and answering all right moving on so
what are the different Azure AI family
of models most of the people have only
heard of D Vinci or use Dai right this
says gbd4 models but soorry gbt 3 models
I need to update the slide it says gbd4
models are available now Dai is a model
which is the most expensive one and is
the one which is like most people use we
don't always need the big model so other
I guess one liner for this slide is
bigger models are not always the best
models they could be really expensive
they are harder to execute they
expensive to run the gpus are really
expensive right now that's why you saw
Nvidia stock shot up like 200% so you
know it's it's a hard time to find uh
gpus I was just talking to a person
outside about we are trying to procure
some h100 and a100 gpus and the timeline
anybody wants to guess how long would it
take 52 weeks to procure gpus which
means if you want to run these models
it's really hard to find this so that's
why Microsoft and other hyperscalers can
provide that scale which individual
companies cannot not so these are the
GB3 models for text generation these are
the models for code generation what does
that mean which means just like GPT can
write text for you it can also write
code for you bad news for developers
right I'm one of them
now what what can gpt3 do you have seen
gpt3 models where they they can write
prompt and text code models you can say
create a SQL quy for me which can do
this and it will generate the SQL query
right but you can also make it more more
complex imagine asking for it giving it
a function and asking it to refact right
giving it a Cobalt programmer who
somebody wrote like six years ago or
maybe 50 years ago then trying to
understand it you can just just give it
to your generative AI GitHub co-pilot
and ask him can you explain this to me
can you optimize this to me can you also
find security flaws in this so sometimes
people think about like what are the use
cases of ch CH GPD so all the things I'm
talking about these are the real world
use cases which is which are going to
really change how fast you can
Implement how fast your company can do
do digital transformation what does that
mean um I'm working with a company right
now and they have 20,000 plus
traditional Terra dat style scripts
imagine migrating to a modern platform
like data breaks with py spark it's
going to be really really hard to do it
manually if you give it to somebody to
do it it's it's going to take them years
if they have to do all of those
conversions they have to handw write it
or use some sort of traditional tool
with generative AI you can pretty much
do the entire thing in maybe less than a
week not just a code conversion but also
writing the unit test the integration
test because that's really important and
don't let anybody let you believe that
just writing the code is going to be
100% done no it has to have a human in
the loop so the another one of the
keyword here is hit or human in the loop
which means human has to review whatever
is coming out of this statement and
that's where we are right now right we
don't have a perfect AI which can just
go ahead and create this whole thing I
hope AI doesn't mind me saying that but
you have this this this thing gets
created and even complex code previously
we have tools like this where you're
like hey I I had a tool back then when I
can give it a database schema it will
generate SQL for me but can it update
the code on demand can it find security
vulnerability can it tell you that
there's a cross-site scripting injection
attack in the code even if it can do
this can it also fix the code for you J
can do all of that it's really magical
you you have to see how GitHub and other
co-pilots work there are little short
demos online uh from Microsoft Inspire
conference and those are like
mindblowing ones all right so these are
some of the the business problems people
typically uh engage
in if you're thinking from an Enterprise
perspective chat gbt is all cool but
what are the things you want to
implement refining and augmenting the
llms how you take large language models
and train it for your use case your
company whether it's retail it's Finance
or Healthcare whether it's you have
heard of Bloomberg GPD right they took
that model and trained it on financial
institutions data so now your llm is
more focused on the finance responses
similarly what if you don't want to
store all the data in open AI Azure open
AI or put it somewhere over there how do
you address that issue you should
address that by creating Vector
databases how do you create security and
privacy around it so nothing actually
gets stored or implemented without you
knowing about uh about it what are the
regulations and policies around it right
um explainability of these models right
responsible execution of these models
responsibility responsible a is a really
really big issue because you know we
have systemic biases all of us and those
get into the AI systems and that is a
really really bad thing it's such a huge
topic I don't have time to actually
address that but it's really important
so I want want to bring it up that you
have to have ai guard rails in place if
not you can look up the horror story of
Microsoft T it was a chatbot it was put
out online and like within it was told
to get trained from the sentiment of the
Twitter user now I don't know about you
guys but it's not a good idea to let
Twitter users train an AI and So within
less than 24 hours that chatbot become
racist homophobic started all kinds of
slurs yeah I mean it's it's just ins say
and how it did that so you have to make
sure that that there are guard rails
around that and and some of the
responses are really gnarly um that
would require like a trigger warning
seriously yeah so all the things you are
trying to put here uh you you saw that
right it can take an hour to just go
over individual point now from a more
technical perspective what are these
model what do these models do there's a
really excellent talk by Andre carpati I
if you've heard of him he's a one of the
biggest uh scientist
uh he was in Tesla now he's back at open
aai he's one of the co-founders of open
aai and he did a talk called state of
GPT if anyone of you is really
interested in understanding the
underpinings of that it's called state
of GPT is available on YouTube 1 hour
best use of your time please go ahead
and check it out also if some of you are
interested in learning how to do prompt
engineering as developers look at Deep
learning AI free courses and hour long
by Andre in Andre in everybody knows
Andre in uh he has done a really good
job at those courses so one of the
things I like to in my talks is to give
you what are the next steps what you can
do to learn more things this is a this
is a way of how your llms actually go
and when you are implementing an
Enterprise model you take a base model
like an open source model or a gp4 and
then train it and fine-tune it on what's
called supervised fine-tuning model so
it is now going to work for your
Enterprise so I do this all day for
multiple different companies and because
the jargons and the communications and
the use cases are quite different top
three use cases for generative AI number
one domain is specific retrieval
augmented
generation so it's a mouthful retrieval
augmented generation or rag means all it
means is that you have bunch of
documents for your company you want to
apply chat GPT style interface on top of
it you want to be able to communicate
and understand that you want to be able
to ask a question like what is my
vacation policy from your own documents
instead of you know calling HR or doing
you can also like you have tons of
documents around your healthcare
insurance and you want to find out what
is your co-pay right CH can tell you
that that do that information in in
comprehensive man and also tell you not
GB I mean gbt llms can tell you those
things and you can get information from
that and give you the citation this is
where I got this information from so
that's really important for you to to be
able to take the power of GPT and llms
and apply to your Enterprise so this is
what it does I think
the the MC is looking at me too see I
have like three minutes left all right
so as your open yeah there's a stick
going to come and pull me out um as your
open a for Enterprise so this these are
the key capabilities you need to have
virtual networks Azure active directory
encryption at rest all of these like
data security things which most of the
who take it for granted who are running
a company or the cesos or the people
that's not provided as outof thee box
offering from op but Azure open does
give you all these uh capabilities in
place so for example data sovereignty
right region based any of you who works
with companies in EU you have to have
data sovereignty it has to be in a data
center over there several times the data
centers are not even available where you
can actually guarantee for open air to
be over executing over there it might
actually round robin it to some other
part of the world which is not
acceptable from an EU perspective so
these governance questions comes into re
comes from like real world
implementation right using charity is
not a real world implementation of
there's a lot of nitty-gritty and Nuance
which goes with implementing these
Solutions in real life
all right next is responsible AI so
these are some of the principles look up
that microsof responsible AI standards
these are some of the standards of
Microsoft follows and of course always
the Shameless plug
here okay um Second Use case I'll talk
about quickly is the synthetic data
generation how many of you actually work
on systems which require synthetic data
there's a synthetic data generation is a
huge use case and the reason is that
whenever you try to generate data test
data it's really hard to generate test
data which is not JN one two three main
street why because systems don't really
understand the context but now we have
llms large language models which can
understand the context and give you
really good understanding of the of the
data so when you get the data it's
actually if you generate for example
Healthcare claim data it actually looks
like healthcare claim data it doesn't
look like random stuff so quickly uh for
that and the last thing I wanted to talk
about is that the is the AI pair
programming which is the GitHub
co-pilot what it does um I don't know
how many of you have actually used used
it but if you have youve used it great
awesome and if you haven't used it you
would use it soon because it's it's
essentially uh going to come for our
jobs the new versions
that have you guys ever even seen the
co-pilots other co-pilots office
co-pilots Microsoft done oh those are
really cool yeah Office 365 ones are
really cool so imagine you have a
developer you go to your developers and
say hey can you create me a dashboard
which compares the uh the the attrition
rate of our company with another company
and then does this and then also take
the labor department data report and
then map it out for me and then show me
the information and like yeah come next
month right now you can actually write
it down in English saying this is
exactly what I want to do point to the
data stores bam you have like English is
the new programming language guys it's
it's it's fascinating what it can do
check out the the GitHub co-pilots for
Office 365 of Microsoft they are really
cool so I am uh running out of time here
and uh thank you very much for inviting
me I mean these are this is a
fascinating topic there's a lot to talk
about and it's like it's just changing
the whole the whole thing so just if you
can take one thing from here is like
generative AI is is here to stay it's
not a fat it's not blockchain oh sorry
not blockchain it's not
cryptocurreny I said it's not
cryptocurrency it's it's different and
it's amazing and you guys should
definitely spend time learning and uh
see how it changes our industry thank
you very
[Applause]
much